um so the this this uh
series of two talks will be on
multi-dimensional and non-linear
mechanism design
uh and i'll give uh some application to
approximation at various points in the
talk as well
today i'm going to focus on
one perspective you can take on this
problem which is to understand
the problem
modularly in other words how do you
construct multiplayer auctions from
single-player auctions
okay and so it's going to focus on
multi-single agent reductions and what
we can learn about the structure of
of good mechanisms from the way that the
multiplayer mechanisms interact with the
single player mechanisms
this is uh
chapter eight of a textbook manuscript
that's i'm currently working on any
decade now it should be ready
um and
chapter eight was something i've been
working intensively on this summer which
is why it's it's very fresh in my mind
it's something i wanted to share with
you this sort of uh
uh
unified way to think about these kinds
of questions
um
unfortunately chapter 8 is actually not
quite ready yet so it's coming soon on
the on the web page here if you're
looking for
notes for for later
okay so i want to start out by giving
you uh some results that will be
consequences of the
the theory i'm going to develop
so you can see what we're working
towards
okay and
what i wanted the the entire
most of this talk will be
and today and even tomorrow we'll be
trying to draw connections between the
multi-dimensional non-linear setting of
mechanism design which is
uh
i guess not well as well understood as
the simpler single dimensional linear
settings that the classical economic
theory has has described
and so in order to understand these more
complex mechanisms i'm actually going to
try to understand them in the same terms
as we understood the single dimensional
linear agent case which is fairly easy
to understand and so i'm going to be
drawing those connections throughout the
the presentations
so i want you to compare these results
to similar results you know from the
single dimensional theory okay so here's
one result suppose you have a
multi-dimensional agent in particular
you could be selling a car that you
could paint either red or blue
and the agents might have a different
value for different colors you could
paint it
okay and so if you imagine that the
values for the colors are drawn iid from
each player's id on the uniform square
for their value for blue or red
then the following auction is optimal
just run the second price auction
with a reserve
and always sell the person who wins
their favorite color car
okay and that should look a lot like
uh
wow i misspelled meyerson's name
um
that should look a lot like the
single-dimensional theory which you're
familiar where the optimal auction for
single bunch of linear agents with iid
players with a
nice distribution is the second price
auction with reserve
here's another result for this time for
non-linear agents
if you're selling a single item to
agents with values uniform 0 1 and they
have a common budget so there's a
maximum they can pay
and that's the same maximum for
everybody
okay so it's a symmetric environment
okay then the optimal auction is
actually also relatively simple it's an
all pay auction
with the reserve price meaning people
aren't willing to bid a certain amount
aren't even considered
but they'll be uh what we'll call
ironing at the top meaning
uh there's uh
the the high valued agents
will all bid the same amount and if
there are more than one that bid that
amount you'll pick a random one to win
so it'll be basically ironed
okay
um i put ironing at the top in
parentheses because when you actually
implement this you don't need to
actually iron at the top the agents will
do it for you
okay you just run the all pay auction
with the reserve
they're not gonna pay more than their
budget so they'll all automatically iron
themselves in the correct way
okay
i'm gonna
uh this theorem is actually uh lafont
and uh
and robert um
but i'm going to give you a proof of
this theorem which follows much more
closely the bilo roberts marginal
revenue approach
okay so these are some results for
optimal mechanisms with
multi-dimensional and non-linear
preferences
i now want to tell you how because we've
viewed these similarly to the single
dimensional
settings we know
we can
automatically get approximation results
that are related
okay so in the multi-dimensional setting
you can automatically get these kinds of
approximation results if i just
post a uniform price
for these iid agents then i'm going to
guarantee an e over e minus 1 which is
1.58 which is the same as 1 over 0.63
that tim was talking about the other day
approximation okay this is via a
a correlation gap result of yan in the
single dimensional setting and it
automatically extends to this
multi-metric setting because we're gonna
have viewed it in the same
uh using the same uh working pieces as a
single dimensional linear case
okay
similarly
a recent
result with
some co-authors who
stayed is actually around in this area
and we'll be probably spending some time
here in this special semester um is that
uh
even if you have uh asymmetric
distributions so imagine here we have
uniform01 and they're all id
but imagine everyone's uniform zero some
upper bound but the upper bounds are
different for different players so now
we have an asymmetric setting
okay um and so the optimal auction there
uh like this one is going to be
basically look like a you know highest
virtual bid wins kind of a thing
uh the same as a single dimensional
setting but that auction's not so
practical so you might wonder can you
get away with just posting a uniform
price that's anonymous to everybody how
well does that do
and in fact the same question was
wondered for single-dimensional linear
agents and it was proved
in these papers and that theorem
automatically extends
okay um an extension for this result the
with uh with common budgets
is that
um well if you have a lot of players
you don't even need a reserve
okay
uh sort of extending the bilo clamper
result to this setting because we viewed
it in the marginal revenue framework to
prove this theorem we can use that same
viewpoint where there's a sort of
marginal revenue version of the belo
klemperer theorem
to show that the all pay auction with no
reserve uh is a good approximation to
the awful one
okay
good so this is sort of um to motivate
what we're doing we're going to try to
understand optimal auctions in the same
terms in which we understood the
single-dimensional linear
case uh these much more complicated
cases of multi-dimensional players or
non-linear players
and because we did that we'll get for
free a lot of extension theorems where
you'll see the single dimensional
results will automatically extend to the
more complex environment
okay so
i'm going to be talking about multi to
agent reductions i'm going to give you
two reductions and they're going to work
in different cases
okay the first an easier reduction i'm
going to call the exon t reduction
and i'm going to reduce the multiplayer
problem to an excellenty pricing problem
for the individual agents and what is
that excellent pricing problem
i'm going to look at each single agent
and ask for any probability that i serve
them what is the best mechanism that
serves them with that excellent
probability
okay if you solve this problem for every
excellent probability
then we'll be able to construct a
mechanism from those
single player mechanisms
okay
and the multi-agent composition
mechanism will be the marginal revenue
mechanism that you may be familiar with
from
below and roberts
okay
this approach does not always work
it will work if and only if
the
single agent problem satisfy a property
which i'll call revenue linearity and
we'll discuss in more detail later
okay but in particular there are two
common cases that you might think about
that satisfy this revenue linearity
assumption
one is the standard single dimensional
linear utility preferences that we're
used to talking about in auction theory
from meyerson's theory
and another case is a large class of
multi-dimensional preferences which i'll
talk in much more detail about tomorrow
okay it includes the uniform zero one
squared example of the red blue car that
i just was talking about
okay and so that theorem on the previous
slide is just an instantiation of this
reduction and its optimality
okay
the other reduction
is i'll call the interim reduction and
it's based on interim allocation rules
of uh the players and in fact solving an
uh an optimization problem that has the
interim allocation rule constrained
everywhere
okay so the single later problem is a
constraint on the entire allocation rule
not just the exanti
probability of service
okay
and the multi-agent composition
mechanism
is going to look like a weighted
a stochastic weighted optimization
okay and i don't want to go into more
detail about what this is now we'll talk
in much more detail later um
one point is this is a much more
complicated procedure this is more
complicated and also this is more
complicated
there are no assumptions you make on the
preferences here to do this
so the multi-dimensional settings you
can't solve because they're not revenue
linear you can solve here with this
approach and you can also solve
nonlinear utility preferences either
single or multi-dimensional doesn't
matter
okay
examples of nonlinear preferences are
budgets like i had the previous slide or
a risk aversion
okay and the example theorem um from
their previous slide about the optimal
auction for budgets is instantiating
this framework
in a symmetric environment where
actually there's some simplification you
can do to make this not so complex
okay so what's my agenda
um
i want my goal really is to have you
understand
what these multi what these uh
reductions look like i have some
intuition for them and understand
what's fundamentally different about the
settings where you can use one or the
other
okay that's that's my goal
okay so i'm going to start with some
examples of seeing optimal single agent
mechanisms so you can see already that
the single agent mechanisms for the two
cases the revenue linear case and the
non-revenue linear case are behaving
very differently
okay
and then once we see them behaving very
differently
we will uh
then uh
you know construct the exony reduction
improve its correctness and then we'll
construct the interim reduction and
prove its correctness
okay
um again the things i want you to think
about here this is a unified framework
for thinking about mechanism design
and i really want to highlight the
differences between the revenue linear
case where basically myerson below
robert's theorem extends to the
non-revenue lender case where it doesn't
have used more sophisticated methods
okay um so i'm going to now work through
some examples of some single agent
mechanisms uh
please feel free to interrupt if you
have uh
questions and want to clarify the
the what these examples are
okay so i'm going to start with the
public budget preference so here's just
a simple public budget preferences which
is the same example i had the first
slide
so i have an agent with a private value
t for receiving some good i can give
them a good with some probability
x
and charge them some payment p
okay they have a public budget and so
their utility function is this
they get utility uh t times x minus p
that's your usual quasi-linear utility
uh except that requires that the payment
be at most the budget if the payment is
bigger than the budget they have
negative util infinity utility
this is a somewhat standard model for
thinking about budgets
okay i'm going to use as a running
example for everything i show you in
this talk will be for t is uniform01
and the budget is a quarter
okay and every every picture is a real
picture
meaning it actually corresponds to when
i show you an apple auction it's that
case the uniform zero one budget a
quarter
okay
whereas uh
the theorems will also will actually be
more general in this case
but i'm not going to show you the more
general picture even though it's going
to be just an obvious extrapolation yeah
i know this minus infinity is completely
standard it wouldn't be good enough
really to do minus the loss
you know so if you're
seeking i have no idea
um
i have no idea
okay so um i want to talk start by
talking about um
some ex-anti-pricing mechanisms meaning
we're in a second we're going to want to
optimize given some constraint on the
excellent probability i serve a player
what is the revenue optimal mechanism
for that constraint so let's just look
at a couple mechanisms that satisfy some
constraint
okay so i'm going to start with an
exante constraint of one-half so meaning
come up with a mechanism which serves
the agent with exotic probability of
half
the mechanism may randomize
and the type of the player is random and
so it's going to be
serving with probably a half in both the
randomization of the mechanism and the
type of the
player okay so here is one mechanism
i could offer
the player a three-quarter lottery
meaning x is three-quarters
and charge them if they want to buy that
lottery one-quarter
remember they have a budget of a quarter
so that's a binding budget constraint
for them
okay and if they don't want that they
can have nothing
so what does this do well you can solve
for what is the indifferent type the
type that doesn't care if they buy this
or not by this by saying okay what type
has uh t times x minus uh
p which is three quarters equal to zero
that t times one quarter times and it's
exactly the type of one third okay
so the allocation rule looks like this
the types with type below a third don't
buy the types above a third buy but they
only buy with probably three quarters
it's a three-quarter lottery
okay and as usual if you're used to
thinking about single dimensional
auction theory the payment in an auction
if i write the allocation rule in type
space like this is just the area
um above the curve so the shaded area
that i've denoted b is actually the
payment that the high type makes which
is equal to the budget which is a
binding budget constraint
here's another example
i want to tell you where the example
comes from
let's suppose i ran a two-player all pay
auction
for a player players of this type and
asked what the equilibrium was
that equilibrium produces an allocation
rule it happens to be this
okay what's going on here i started with
highest bid winds
right
but if i just run highest bid wins the
top guys are going to over spend their
budget
so they want to lower they want to you
know pull themselves with lower types
okay but if the top players start
pulling themselves then some lower
players gonna also want to pull because
then they get it you know they win with
some prop higher probability because
they get a chance at winning when
they're pulled with the high types too
so
the high types drop down the low type
similar types drop up and you get
the lowest site that's indifferent
between dropping up is this guy everyone
else is as before and these guys are all
pooled
okay and you can calculate out the area
this b it's exactly a quarter as before
and you could calculate out the
probability of
the
x anti probability and it's also one
half as i desired
okay these are two mechanisms
good
let's think about this exxon t
pricing question i want to come up with
the single player mechanism
that has the highest revenue
but serves the exxon the probability uh
say at most one half what is that
give your hand it's one of these which
one
biggest area
the biggest area so the bees are both
the same for them
right so the question
right the thing is is that everyone here
who wins pays b
and here some of the people pay some
lower amount because the guy with the
type here pays the area above the curve
for that type
right so here
we sell with probably a quarter and
everyone pays b here we sell with
probably
sorry a half and everyone pays b here we
sell probably a half but some people
don't pay b
does that make it easier which one's
bigger
okay in fact a is optimal
okay and in fact uh the theorem you can
show is that a mechanism of this form is
optimal and
what is what is all i want you to get
from this is the following
is that
the probability of the lottery which was
three quarters here
changes with your excellent probability
okay so you're taking this curve and
you know scrunching it down as you
change the probabilities
okay uh any any questions on this
we'll revisit the example further when
once you make it more complicated but
i'm happy to
so
i didn't i also by the way i also did
not tell you what happens when the
budget's not binding when what is not
binding it's obvious what happens you
just post a price
okay so this is the budget binding case
here
and the budget obviously not binding
when this equation can't be satisfied by
anything
so the mechanism of the lip was also for
two agents and no
this is a single player question
i just this came from somewhere i looked
at what the interim allocation rule was
for a two-player mechanism and this is
what happens
okay
this
you know doesn't come from any
two-player mechanism that i ever thought
of it's just happens to be a
single-player mechanic you could post
this lottery what happens then
okay let's move on to unit demand
preferences okay so
um
you should not say single dimensional
there unit demand preference is
multi-dimensional
how am i going to notate this sorry this
notation is a little bit clunky
an allocation is going to be a probably
of getting item alternative one or
alternative two
okay um it better be that your your unit
demands you only want one thing so
better be that the total number of
things you get is the most one
okay you'll have a payment p
sorry jason i don't understand
next one is the problem do i get the
first code
all right x
one is the probability you get the first
item
x2 is a probably the second item
if x1 and x2 are both 0.9
i might get both items but i might not
get any items so you are thinking about
these as independent random variables
they are not these are the probability
of getting it's like the simplex there
are two outcomes you get one two or zero
and it's a simplex so some sort most one
okay your private value has two
coordinates your utility is just your
the sum of your value for the things you
get
uh your standard linear utility
definition
okay my running example is t is going to
be uniform 0 1 squared
okay i want to do the exact same thing
we did before i want to ask you what are
some
uh what are some mechanisms that serve
with excellent probability q hat for say
q out equals one half
okay here's something you could do
only ever sell item one
if i want to sell with probably a half
and i only want to sell item one i
better post the price for half the
players uniform zero one
is there's something else you could do
you have your corresponds to x1 plus x2
uh qhat corresponds no to the
probability yeah so the probability they
buy anything
an expectation over the types and both
could be random the types and also the
x's
but so either the first one yes that's
correct
um and in fact later i'll just say uh x
to denote the sum of the two so i need x
less than one
so that's something i could do
um
i could also sell them the lottery
okay and this would actually be a price
one half
so at price one half
you can either get uh
you get 50 50 of the first item or the
second item
okay but so if you win you win probably
one though
right
so what's the heading
so this is uniform lottery over items
because the right-hand example
have two
half or two height
they both have q out equals one-half
except that you only have a high type
with probably one half
so there's probably one conditional on
exactly
and both of these you serve with
probably one condition i'm being served
okay but the only some types will be
served and that's typing server the
areas given by
their shaded regions
okay here is another allocation rule
it's a uniform pricing
of a price of square root one half y
square root one half well i want this
area to be one half and i want this area
to be one half which is the same as this
area being a half and that area is a
half if my price is well
square root one half
okay
so say some so this is for unit demand
so
q hat the example probability of service
kind of makes sense
but say if it was additive how would you
define
i would have to define a different kind
of exonte problem for additive if i had
a
feasibility constraint across the
multiple agents that have the
externality of for the different items
so i'm going to be focusing today on
settings where the externality between
players is a single dimensional
externality okay if you have a
multi-dimensional accidentality between
players which what causes i believe is
asking about then you'll need to find a
different exony pricing problem i'm not
going to talk about that today
the different exony pricing problem is
actually inside eli's 2011 paper
okay so good i have three mechanisms
here i'll give you a hint one of them is
optimal which one is it
the one on the other
yeah so
wait i called them all a
you can yeah somebody with deadlock
um
okay so uh so c is right and if you
remember the first slide you should
recognize c being the the right answer
um
and in general what's the right answer
it's gonna be
uh the uniform price that uh
is calculated here
what is this max this max is because
actually when you when you have too high
a probability you actually don't want to
sell with that total probabilities
you're allowed to like not sell with the
total probability in the next pricing
problem
okay
so i want to post the price that
corresponds to the price that has this
area exactly equal to q hat
okay but i don't want to go below square
root one third which is what this
constraint is saying
how do you tell from looking at the
picture
you can't in fact and the no no so i
want to
i want to remind you my agenda my
agendas give you examples of what
optimal mechanisms look like in a single
agent setting i'm then going to talk
about the reduction we're focusing on
how do we build optimizes from the
single agent mechanisms and knowing what
the single mechanisms look like is going
to help us do that
tomorrow i'm going to go and derive
how to show that these are optimal
okay
good any other questions
yeah
i know this may be a silly question but
um
it gives some motivation as to why we
would want
when we're when are we given like an
exogenous probability that we want to
select sample with
no i won't actually and the reason why i
won't is because i'm using it as a tool
to build the optimal mechanism
okay so i don't actually care about that
question in itself
okay i care about that question as a
building block in constructing uh
optimal multiplayer mechanisms
one of the reasons why
i think this viewpoint as a reduction is
so important is that if you look at some
of the literature where people are
studying single player problems
they're not necessarily studying these
ones
and they should be because these are the
ones from which you can construct
multiplayer mechanisms
okay so um
so that
completes my uh
you know survey by example of exante
pricings okay i now want to talk about
the more complicated single player
problem which the second kind of
reduction is going to use which is
interim pricings
okay so to do that i'm going to have to
to
introduce some
notation for allocation rules etc
okay
so
um i'm gonna define the allocation rule
as of uh for types to be x is just the
probability that the type is is served
and answering a previous question of uh
costas that's gonna be in the unit
demand case it's the the sum of the
probabilities you get either item is to
probably get anything
okay
so if you have a mechanism in mind
and we will usually have a mechanism in
mind
then i can measure the relative strength
of two different types of the players
from the distribution
by asking which one has a higher service
probability in that mechanism
okay
and i'm going to call the quantile of an
agent q
to be the measure of types with higher
allocation probability in the mechanism
that we were thinking about
okay so given a mechanism i look at all
the allocation probabilities what's the
probability that a random type has a
higher allocation probability than this
type that's the quantile of the type
okay
and the
important definition the important
property of quantiles is that
for any type from the distribution
quantile's always uniform zero one
because any ordering by strength will
always give you an ordering
uh zero one when you look at their
relative strength
okay
so now i'm going to take my allocation
rule in typespace and define an
allocation rule in quantile space
okay which if you add a mapping types
quantiles just maps them
okay but let's actually think about what
that is so the allocation rule in
quantile space
is if you take
the allocation probabilities of the
player of the types
and you sort them
in decreasing probability with widths
equal to sort of the probability they
show up
then you get this allocation rule in
quantile space
okay for discrete type spaces it's very
intuitive okay for discrete type spaces
make a rectangle with width the
probability the type shows up and height
the probability that type is served
you take those rectangles you sort them
in decreasing order
and you'll the the profile the top
profile will be an allocation rule
okay this is the allocation rule in
general for a mechanism in quantum space
okay let's do some examples so public
budgets we saw this allocation rule
before in typespace
types were just uniform zero one
so what is the allocation rule in
quantile space
well
you know this measure one half of types
all get served with the highest
probability which is three quarters so
there's that big rectangle
and then these other infinitesimal
agents get served with decreasing uh
probability and so they're just here
okay and actually for uniform zero one
it's just you just flip it
okay
f is the density function
okay so what about this unit demand
example what's the allocation rule here
well these types receive a good with
certainty
what measure are there they're a half of
them these types receive the type not at
all so if i take the allocation we'll
sort it and put it in probability space
then a half measure get it with
certainty a half measure get nothing
this is the allocation rule
in quantile space
okay i now i'm ready to define this
interim pricing problem
okay the interim pricing problem assumes
that i'm given an allocation constraint
y which is the same form as an
allocation rule in quantile space
okay i'm going to use hats by the way
for constraints every time i constrain
i'll put a hat on it
okay so y is just a monotone decreasing
function from 0 1 to 0 1 y hat
okay
and what i would like you to do
is come up with a stationary
transformation from quantiles
to quantiles so from uniforms from zero
one to zero one
that is stationary so
if i
um
take a random quantile from uniform zero
one and i put it in my transformation i
get a random variable it's also uniform
zero one
okay so what is stationary i
don't know stationary means in this
context
good so
um
i'm going to put into sigma
a quantile q
that quantile q is drawn from the
uniform distribution
i would like the expected value of sigma
q
if i don't tell uq to also be from the
uniform distribution
that's what i mean by stationary
it takes a distribution as input
and
if that distribution's uniform gives you
the same distribution out
yeah
if you wanted only for the uniform
distribution only for the uniform
distribution
okay
i want you to find one of these one of
these sigmas
okay
and then i want you to find me a single
agent mechanism with allocation
rule
that
is upper bounded by
the expected allocation constraint when
i remap things by sigma
no you're finding both these things
so why wouldn't i take sigma as the
identity because if you take sigma's
identity you won't be able to come up
with as good mechanisms as if you don't
take sigma as the identity
okay that would that would constrain you
artificially
is it is it a permutation
understand what's going on here
um i'll tell you one of the kinds of
things you're going to want to do with
sigma
you're going to want to take an interval
between a and b
and you're going to want to just
uniformly redraw it
so if i condition on a type being in
some interval quantile begin a b
and i ignore it and i redraw a new type
from that interval
what's the new distribution it's still
uniform zero one
okay
that's how we're going to use sigma in
constructions i want to um
give you another way if you find this
definition confusing i'm happy for you
to take
the theorem i'm going to prove as the
definition instead
okay so let's define the cumulative
allocation rule as just its integral
okay so
the cumulation rule for q hat is
integrating the allocation rule from
zero to q hat
okay in other words
let's think about this
q hat is a constraint on on
on the quantile
right so i take all the players with
quantile
uh stronger than q hat
and asked what's their expected
probability of being served
so
the allocation
rule y is feasible for allocation
constraint y hat if and only if
the queue of allocation rules satisfy
the pointwise
domination condition
this is like
so um
this is like basically
ask for majorization basically if you
want to think of it that way
okay
it's like a majorization property
for those of you know what that means is
the definition of feasible is there
exists sigma such that the second point
holds
yes
so you'll say y is feasible if there
exist sigma such that this is true
okay
if i mean
the theorem is that these are the same
things so if you found that definition
confusing
you can just take this as the definition
okay in other words it's a constraint on
every prefix of strongest types of the
excellent probability you serve type in
that prefix
okay
i want to actually prove this theorem
by showing you how to
construct the sigma that you want for
this theorem
okay and the main idea is that
if i take an allocation rule y
and i use some sigma that re-samples on
some interval a b by
ignoring the quant actual quantile that
was in a b and drawing uniformly from a
b instead
okay that'll replace
uh the allocation
constraint y hat little y hat with is
the expectation
and that it replaces the cumulative
allocation rule
with a line segment connecting the two
points
okay so here are pictures okay let's
suppose
my allocation constraint y hat is
the
straight line the 45 degree line
and let's suppose the allocation rule y
i want to implement is this stair
function the black stair function and
this
violates richard's property that it's
always pointwise less than it
okay but we can actually implement this
stair function from this allocator
allocation constraint y
using such a sigma
okay how are we going to do it
the first thing i'm going to do is throw
out probability to make the xonti
probabilities the same
notice that
y capital y of one is just the total
probability that guys served
okay so
this point and this point this is the
excellent probability of y hat this is
the extent probability of y
how can i make them the same
well if your type is if you're in the
weakest types here i'll just set your y
hat to zero
okay that would take this curve which is
still increasing and make it flat
okay so that's how i go from the dotted
line to this one truncated here
then the next thing i want to do
is
use the fact that resampling on interval
a b
is replacing a line segment accumulation
allocation rule so if i want to take
this curve which goes like that and make
it look like this curve here
i can just take that interval and
resample it
okay so i resample between zero and
this
somewhere here
okay and then i get this dotted curve
okay and then i can re-sample on this
interval to take that thing and flatten
it to this line
okay
that's the construction
can you motivate this a little bit like
where's this allocation constraint
coming from
again
again no i don't want to motivate it the
same answer is before i don't care about
these problems these problems are coming
from a multi-agent reduction i'm going
to have to solve them
no but it's good to remember that so
thanks for asking
just say it's going to be a separation
oracle for something
okay so i want to now look at example
uh interim pricings and my example is
going to be for the allocation
constraint y hat that's the minus 45
degree line is the
the one we were talking about in the
previous slide
okay
so um
here i've shown the constraint with a
dotted line
and i've shown what is the optimal
allocation rule for the public budget
example previously given that allocation
constraint okay and what does it do
it irons the top it reserve prices the
bottom and then some middle middle
interval it's greedy it's the highest
type wins
or smallest quantile the strongest
quantile wins
okay
and that corresponds back in type space
to this allocation rule
okay
good what about the unit demand case
again taking the exact same unit demand
example the allocation constraint y hat
is the minus 45 degree line
the optimal allocation has this
allocation rule here
just the reserve price
greedy allocating by strongest quantile
until the reserve price
and the mechanism in two-dimensional
space looks like this the reserve price
as i said before is square root
one-third
and we'll allocate with increasing
probability to the types as they get
highest a strong a higher
uh highest coordinate
okay so note these types are the ones
where they prefer item one these are the
types to prefer item two
and we're allocating probability in
terms of their highest coordinate
okay again
for this part of the talk i don't need
you to understand
how to get this from the constraint or
anything i just want you to understand
what these things look like
okay i want to point out
something is quite different about these
two scenarios which i haven't written
here in this slide i'll just tell it to
you
this um
so i have written it here so this
reserve is the same reserve that you
would get for every single allocation
constraint y hat
okay for every single allocation
constraint y hat it would look y would
look exactly like y hat down to the
quantile the uh uh two thirds which
corresponds to reserve of square root
one third and price in
price space
okay
that is not the same
for
the
the public budget example
these two thresholds which one of them
is where you iron one of them is where
you put the reserve price
these will be different
for every allocation rule you choose
okay
and the thing that's important about
that
is
in the in the unit demand case there's
something that's sort of unchanging
about your observation problem
no matter what the constraint is the
problem is unchanging whereas for the
public budget case
actually things are moving you change
your allocation rule
the things that were relevant before are
no longer relevant you have to think
about other things
yeah a little bit confused when you talk
about changing your allocation rule
versus changing y hat i'm sort of
thinking of why hat is this sort of
exogenous unmotivated thing that's
coming from space yeah why is the thing
we actually want to implement right yeah
so
can you clarify a little bit yeah
so i'm thinking about changing y hat
and asking
how the aqua mechanism changes and these
things i need to know so when i give you
the y hat of one minus q
okay meaning this one i got these
particular
uh
you know iron the top and reserve price
the bottom with these particular
parameters
those parameters depend on y hat i'll
give you a different y hat
you get the exact same structural
picture
for iron the top reserved price the
bottom
but the reserve price will be different
and the ironing rate will be different
okay that does not happen here
for every single y hat you get the exact
same reserved price
okay
one thing we can point out from this
previous slide is
what was the optimal the optimal
excellent mechanisms for this problem
they were just posting a uniform price
right
what is this mechanism
it actually looks just like a convex
combination of posting uniform price for
different probabilities of posting the
price
okay so
the interim optimal mechanism is going
to become a combination of example
mechanisms
in the unit demand example that's not
true in the public budget example
okay
also
the ordering on types
so we said we defined uh
we said that for every mechanism
you could
map types to quantiles by looking at the
probability that the type wins in that
mechanism
so
for the unit demand example for every
single allocation constraint you give it
the same ordering is is fine
okay the origins are consistent
there's one ordering on types that's
always ordering and in fact that
ordering is is kind of obvious to see
you want to order them by their highest
coordinate because that tells you when
they're going to win or not because
they're all basically competing in this
auction for who's got the highest
favorite item
okay so i'm calling that second profit
orderability property order ability when
every single agent interim mechanism has
the same order on types
okay
i'm going to define some notation so if
i give you a constraint y hat and i want
you to optimize revenue subject that
interim constraint y hat i'm going to
denote that by rev of y hat as the
optimal revenue i get for that
constraint
okay then this revenue linearity
property more formally is just the
following if i give you two allocation
constraints that something to be a third
constraint then the revenue is just the
sum the optimal revenues for those
constraints is just their sum
so natural linearity property defined on
this revenue operator on the allocation
constraints
okay
and this is not a coincidence for the
uniform case it's actually a fact for
every revenue linear case
revenue linearity implies order ability
so you'll always get this convenient
ordering property if you have revenue
linearity
in the congress
no
and the converse
let's see
let me not say anything right now
yeah think of it as taking a comments
combination instead of a direct sum like
that like i've written here
so
right y hat as the commas combination of
two other
allocation rules and then my
first one will be the coefficient of the
first one times this first one and this
is the coefficient of the second one
times the second one
okay so think of it as convex
combination
yeah the y hats are interim constraints
yes
okay i now want to give you the
excellent reduction
okay in particular i'm going to show you
that revenue linearity is going to imply
that the myerson beulah roberts
mechanism of marginal revenue
maximization is just going to extend
naturally to give you the awful
mechanism for these settings
okay so um
to define marginal revenue
um
we've
uh for every allocat every x anti
constraint q hat
we've solved the x anti pricing problem
let's define r of q hat to be the
revenue for every q hat
and then these this will define a
revenue curve
which
is going to be a nice uh actually
concave function i can take its
derivative
and let that derivative be the marginal
revenue and call the marginal revenue
okay and then the theorem that you will
recognize from the single dimensional
theory is the following
that
uh the optimal revenue for a constraint
y hat is just equal to its marginal
revenue
meaning that revenue is equal to the
expectation of if i were to view sort of
marginal rate like
as a virtual value
i get sort of the
the surplus of marginal revenue
um
this this theorem has the assumption of
revenue linearity i should have written
it here
do i have this interview
y hats are always interim yes yes y and
y hats are interim allocation rules
okay so here's the proof
so another way to reinterpret what this
revenue from the exxon pricing is
is actually the the revenue of the
interim mechanism with a constraint of
steps from one to zero at q hat
okay so if i had y hat is equal to this
i would get optimal revenue equal to r
of q hat
okay
and then any allocation constraint y hat
can be viewed as a convex combination of
reverse step functions
coefficients are the negative derivative
of the allocation rule
okay
so then using revenue linearity
i can write the expected revenue
as well this is just the combat
combination of a whole bunch of other
step mechanisms
what
is this revenue therefore its revenue is
the probability that i run the q app
mechanism times the revenue of the q hat
mechanism which is this
okay and that expectation you can view
as an integral and you can integrate it
by parts to switch where the integ the
derivative is to get the marginal
revenue definition
this is exactly
um
the analysis you would have done if uh
you were doing a single dimensional case
yeah
great question let's remember that
so the interim pricing problem for every
allocation constraint y
i want to find a mechanism
uh every allocation constraint y hat i
want to find a mechanism y
that is constrained by that mechanism
via some
resampling transformation sigma
okay over all such
mechanisms that satisfy this constraint
that's your question okay and i gave you
some examples of that
where he here's was what i did when i
gave you allocation constraint y hat you
came up with this y
right when i gave you this alkene
y hat the same allocation what happened
i had a public budget it gave me this
other y
so are there so sorry so there are
prices also
um
yeah so
i've just written this in terms of the
allocation rule
but they're prices that make it all
incentive compatible because i this is
over single agent mechanisms that are
intentional compatible
okay but those i don't talk about here
i'm just talking about the allocation
control and you want to maximize the
revenue that comes from that
that's implicit in that optimization
question
all right just make sure you understand
so there's
you are optimizing both over sigma and
then for a fixed sigma you still have to
optimize over the mechanism it's not
there for a fixed sigma there's
that is correct and but i would view it
slightly differently as when you
optimize y there'll be an implicit
signal that comes out of it
so in fact i would just write this
constraint as your constraints and
ignore sigma and just optimize with this
constraint
okay and you'll get sigma for free
so for every sigma there is an ic
mechanism
um
yeah
you can recycle types in whatever way
yeah
and that's not so exciting
because for every sigma the allocation
rule's mocked on for every month and
allocation where i can start the
mechanism
okay so that's the proof that revenant
optimal revenue is always equal to
marginal revenue
yeah so this convex combination of
allocation rules is that coming out of
the expectation over the quantiles is
that what's happening here
yes so the point is i have a monotone
decreasing function
okay i can write every monsoon
decreasing function as a convex
combination of functions that step down
right where the probability on this is
the negative derivative of that function
at this point
okay so this equate this first part of
the equation is just rewriting
um the
revenue linearity equation
where the terms in it are the you know
the allocation will weighted by the
probability that i i do that i have that
allocation rule in there
so the analysis is this is for single
dimensional setting now this is for any
setting that's revenue linear i should
have written that here
so for revenue linear settings this
holds the only assumption i used was
revenue linearity here
so i'm keeping track of the allocation
as a single dimensional quantity here
so i guess i'm going so my your previous
claim that the allocation is monotone
when you look at it in the quantum space
there's a mapping from the
multi-dimensional preferences to this
quantile space
if you shuffle that in whatever way
you're right you don't get it at ic but
i'm mapping quantiles to quantiles in my
construction not types to quantiles
but you're correct that when you solve
this problem
you implicitly have to figure out the
mapping from types to quantiles because
any mechanism will map types to
quantiles as i defined on the previous
slide there induces a mapping so you
must have figured that
out okay
so your problem here is i give you this
white hat in control space
you have to figure out
uh the mappings
figure out
look so every mechanism induces an
allocation con allocation rule
right
so over all mechanisms
find one that uses a rule that satisfies
let's forget this just this property
um i have an ic assumption which means
this mechanism basically looks to you by
the via the taxation principle like a
menu you always choose your favorite
outcome
okay that might not be
your favorite item if it's priced higher
than your other item in some mechanism
right in the unit demand example i was
talking about it will always turn out to
be that way but you only notice that
once you solve the single player problem
completely which i haven't done yet i'm
going to do tomorrow
okay so that's a detail of the single
player problem which i don't want to
talk about today we'll talk about that
in in in great depth tomorrow
um you know items or whatever and sound
compatibility constraints
okay um
good so let's now say
what is the optimal multi-agent
mechanism under the linearity property
and you can define the marginal revenue
mechanism for orderable agents and
remember every revenue linear agent is
an orderable agent because revenue
linearity implies order ability
so step one is you map agent types to
quantiles via the ordering that's
it that's implicit in the single agent
problems
okay so
this is a type profile so it's all the
types of players and you get a quantile
profile by this mapping
then i'm going to calculate the marginal
revenues of all of the agents at the
quantiles i get from this mapping
okay
and then i'm going to serve the agents
to maximize the total
uh
surplus of marginal revenue
i find the x
i's that are feasible and maximize the
sum
for a single agent i just choose the guy
with the highest positive marginal
revenue
okay and finally to find the outcome and
payments for each player
i'm going to look at how much they could
increase their quantile meaning go to
lower types
and still be served
to find a critical quantile which is the
quantile at which they couldn't increase
it anymore
okay that critical quantile
has a mechanism that's defined by
solving the exony problem for that
quantile
that player sees
the the mechanism that's the excellent
mechanism for that quantile
so now to ask answer the question of why
do we care about these mechanisms those
actually appear
in the construction here you're going to
then
you know use that excellent mechanism
and notice that
this player has higher this player will
always actually buy
the uh be served by this mechanism
jason is the critical quantile the one
in which which probably falls all the
way to zero or it calls it all lower
than what your current
probability is i'm not sure this
critical contact that's a great question
so and
because implicit in that question is
that
these players might be served with
probabilities
but actually if once you've done this x
is going to be 0 1.
okay and that's going to come out so in
fact a property we had in a single
dimensional setting which was the
allocation who wins and who loses is
deterministic
is maintained in this setting it will
always be zero or one
okay
okay so the theorem is this mechanism is
optimal
how do you prove this well we point-wise
optimize marginal revenue and marginal
revenue is equal to optimal revenue
always by the previous theorem um so we
have to have optimized revenue now is it
incentive compatible well the revenue
curves are concave so the marginal
revenue occurs are monotone so these
critical quantiles i needed here exists
and this is ic
which is the standard proof that you
approved this mechanism if you were
roger meyerson
okay
okay so um i want to return to
my example which was revenue linear
which is the uniform 0 1 squared case so
the red blue car types id uniform 0 1
and reinterpret what this marginal
revenue mechanism is and we'll see we
get the exact same thing i said i would
get at the very beginning
okay so
again
the uniform zero one agent is revenue
linear and the revenue curve r of cube
is it comes from posting a price a
square root one minus q hat
okay so it looks like this
okay
you can plot out what the revenue you
get from this is if you post this price
and you're selling with probability q
hat your revenue is q hat times the
price you get the q times square root 1
minus q at that's the revenue curve
which has this form and you can see it's
optimized at q hat equal two thirds
okay
um
how do we map types to quantiles
well by strength and remember the
the excellent mechanisms are always sort
of just posting higher and lower uniform
prices so the stronger players are the
ones that have a higher value for their
favorite item
okay and so what is that so given your
type is t red t blue then your quantile
is one minus the max of t red t blue
squared which is how you can convert if
your type was here and t t-max is here
you convert that back into probability
space by asking how many people are
stronger than you
okay
so now i want to maximize marginal
revenue i have an iid setting so as
usual
the values of marginal revenues don't
matter it's just the ordering matters
and so we just care about who has the
highest marginal revenue and the person
with the the smallest quantile has the
highest marginal revenue
right
um and they're the person with the
highest favorite item coordinate
okay so serve the agent with the
smallest quantile less than two-thirds
and they start to have negative marginal
revenue
um and so that's serve the agent with
the highest maximum value charge the
second highest maximum value or reserve
square root one third
the same that because my side would be
optimal on the first slide
okay
and so revenue linearity implies this
mechanism is indeed optimal
can you remind me how you knew this was
revenue linear and more generally
how you know in the setting of revenue
um
so i didn't give you a general method
for determining whether a setting was
revenue linear
um
i will give you a general method
tomorrow for determining whether a
setting is linear
so i'll give you two answers one you can
solve a program
to check revenue linearity
a mathematical program you can just plug
it in and has to do with revenue linear
it's not a very nice answer
the other answer is you could observe
the structure
of the single of the
interim opel mechanisms which is what we
did today
so we saw
this interim awful mechanism for the
unit demand case
and
if you look at this allocation rule
what is it doing it's gradually
increasing probability as you get higher
coordinate for your favorite item
okay what were the optimal example
mechanisms
they were just posting uniform price
so you can implement this allocation by
taking a comment combination of those
exacting mechanisms
therefore it's revenue linear
okay
that didn't that didn't depend on the
allocation constraint
exactly and that's the point so the
point is it will always look like this
for any allocation constraint
um it'll have this exact same reserve
price and it'll be greedy up to that
reserve so the curve will match the
thing
up to the reserve then it'll drop to
zero
more questions
i think that are not linear
okay so um i am out of time
which means i'm going to push the
discussion of the general setting to
tomorrow
um when things are not revenue linear
okay but so to conclude for today
we saw
two examples unit demand public
public budget and unit demand
they behave very differently when i look
at their single agent problems
and the structure of the behavior of the
single agent problem for the demand case
was especially nice
which will allow us to use very simple
marginal revenue tools to understand
what alpha mechanisms are
okay so next time we'll see
how to
how to
solve for alpha mechanisms when we don't
have this nice structural property in
particular we'll work out the optimal
mechanism for the public budget example
i'll do much other things as well
you